je sais pas où clément morin crise de
montage mais en tout cas c'est l'intro
de la vidéo bienvenue à tous il savait
avant les vacances j'ai fait une petite
vidéo mais gueule dans laquelle je
m'étais régalé avec un concept où il y
avait des images où il y avait des gens
dessus et moi j'étais parmi les gens et
fallait me trouver aujourd'hui on fait
évoluer le concept oui je sais c'était à
coeur moi mais j'ai trop aimé le faire
alors je leur fais tout de suite bref
aujourd'hui on va pas s'incruster dans
des images où il ya plein de gens et je
suis parmi les gens voient s'incruster
dans des images où je suis dupliquer
partout et parmi tous les mois que ya
sur l'image
il y en a un qui est le vrai moi en
direct bien évidemment j'ai préparé
plusieurs endroits début ça va être
assez simple ça va devenir de plus en
plus dur je vous préviens il se peut que
la qualité audio soit un peu moins bien
que d'habitude parce que je vais être
loin du micro déjà et qu'ensuite j'ai
mis les gens sur haut parleur parce que
tous les autres mois sur les images
n'ont pas de casque
donc si j'en ai un je vais grillé
instantanément voilà j'ai hâte
commençons je fais le petit tweet ya
plein de gens probablement pendant que
cette instruction déjà sur ma gueule à
attendre alors allons-y
couasnon tu as déjà fait corps je donne
une image d'unité vélo j'ai déjà vu le
parlement non c'est juste que le concept
se ressemblent parce que j'ai plein
d'idées mais sinon non c'était pas ça
exactement 1 rue bon ça vraiment sur la
plus bue ça que j'ai eu avec un être
humain de toute ma vie
et merde il malgré tout de suite pensé à
une petite est bien attention mais non
je suis la musique est à bout c'est le
galsi
c'est le prêt je réponds tu as ta place
est la première personne est bien bien
joué tu es chanceux témoigne dédicacé
hockey quand tu t'appelles thomas gall
thomas gars est un gros big up à thomas
gars c'est le gars sur il met des
vêtements magnifiques et très sympa et
il a dit que j'étais pas beau et ça ça
je m'en souviendrai longtemps j'en sais
je sais pas moi qui montre les vidéos tu
sais ça se trouve tu seras sa sortie
sera pas à clément écoute je continue à
apprendre montreux mais et puis et puis
voilà je le tape je te fais des bisous
atterri sur youtube y est à + bisous
avec merci beaucoup
tu es dans le bus way
il ya du monde dans le but cela la paire
ce pas je me disais tu m'as vu
ouais je te mangerais bien jouer la
gagne et bien je vais vraiment je peux
te montrer la prochaine scène en
exclusivité c'est toi qui la voient là
je te montre la deuxième attention non
et ben écoute ferro bontrager ah bah
merci et je me salue tient à l'horizon
chérèque
oh il commence assez clair ces rouleaux
non assise c'est relou sais rien je suis
là tu sautes le poteau crois tu m'as pas
bouger tellement pas que tu ressembles
exactement au pas ces gens ici savent
j'ai bien travaillé je suis content tu
connais j'ai bien travaillé cet ep 2
avec les mots exacts il vraiment emma
est cool merci à toi dévolu sur leur
école va c'est une très bonne journée
soirée du coup vous convenez soir et
puis assez vite et écoute tarification à
bas tarif est la mienne aussi tu vois
c'est la première réussi à piéger qui
m'a pas vu je suis refait à driver
pierre s'y tient elle était trop gentil
je viens de voir est tu sais que tu as
triché
tu le sais oui je sais maman c'est pas
ta faute de la vienne c'est horrible tu
me dois bien ça parce que je suis passé
dans une de tes vidéos ya deux ans je
crois est en fait je te reconnais pas
parce que tu as fait ton fond et étaient
déguisés et du coup tu vas avait appelé
dans la vidéo j'en avais pas parlé non
pas du tout oh c'est fou et là tu as
besoin fréquent même il était temps et
comment ça va qu'est ce qui s'est passé
du coup depuis tout ce temps
en deux ans humbert
très peu de choses ont très peu de
choses vu la longueur l'arrivant situe
en fait d'armes si tu veux tout savoir
pas même un peu meilleur puis en plus
les profs sont pas très sympa alors eh
ben tu sais quoi on va leur dire un
petit message là soyez sympas les profs
voilà c'était c'était un discours rapide
mais je pense qu'on a là l'essentiel
tout de suite traitement à l'eau
on la refait hockey dès que je pars tu
fais moi mais ce concept est fou et
c'est parti hello poésie oui je suis là
sur le poteau ici là qu'est ce que tu
fais là bas c'est mon concept et c'est
bien moi je joue très mal on le super
mal c'est terrible puisque je vais te
montrer la prochaine ce n est jamais
dire ce qu'ils en pensent tu es prête
elle est bien ou pas c'est génial et moi
merci ça fait situe là il était sincère
j'en ai eu un sincère au final bon bah
écoutes je fais des gros bisous et je
dois enchaîner tu connais les vidéos
mais merci d'être passé ça fait plaisir
même si toi aussi merci beaucoup tiendra
bientôt tunisie mais non c'est pas
squeeze alors si oui leo quelqu'un en
attendant brouille elle a lancé le but
évident de trouver sans que je bouge
huit ans attends je l excès non non non
non c'est triste mais je me retournais
évidemment que moi depuis on fait ça oui
bah oui je suis un pêcheur je suis un
je peux le dire non non mais t'es
tu trouves ça je souffre je suis pas
s'il debout fenêtre est pas du tout
alors pas mal non ah ouais franchement
je me reconnaissent les devants
franchement elle j'étais tout au fond tu
te bien je suis une je vais pas
mettre tous devant et belle couche est
une magnifique année et travaille bien
repose toi bien qu'il vient et puis au
plaisir sur you tube mercy bisou au fond
là-bas mais max abuser c'est trop fort
mais bon matelas chance à
merveille ouais ben on attend plus les
amis il est maintenant temps de passer à
cette scène qui est le tueur mais
préférait je veux l'adorent et aux os 5
secondes mais il faut que tu lis des
choses et si clément trouve ça
intéressant edgar de montage on y va
c'est parti piscine voiture pile aux
cellules où ses parents d'hommes c'était
un homme j'ai préféré tout ce que tu
viens dire c'était objets préférés
franchement ce monde d'hommes viens
jouer à temps je veux sa pub sur l'adage
bon ok mais alors tu promets de jouer le
jeu tu me dis pas où je suis aucun souci
vas-y je triche un peu je vous avoue
mais ce paravent deux premiers pas du
tout là bas écouter passer une bonne
soirée frères et soeurs mais le gros
bisous bonne année a très vite ta bonne
année scolaire chantant spa nous voulons
[Musique]
au nom des droits non j'étais juste là
cachées d'aller la nuit délabrement du
sénégal ont été trouvés et tu vas
trouver bien joué à bientôt c'est gentil
merci attendait cela l ai trouvé parfois
quand je me cale derrière ça marche trop
bon assez long j'étais un peu parce que
c'est bon là je me casse je triche pas
bravo bah ça va aussi de ce machin
mon concept j'ai le droit dans ma vie ma
non tu te débrouilles tu vois bien qu'il
ya des bras et y'a personne
j'adore celui-là il est vraiment bien
aux racines prochain il arriva à me
trouver on va voir je t'aimerai il tend
à appuyer sur la touche parce que tu as
cru que je n'entendais pas je me suis
emporté
ça va ou quoi donc tu pas vu vite
oui je les tournantes ou qui dépasse et
amer bon gros menton d'adrien avec
batterie je vais changer de seine la
prochaine
elle est un peu mind fuck parce qu'en
fait je suis dans un reflet du miroir
c'est ma mère n'ont jusqu'ici c'est pas
genre je te vois c'est bon les gars je
sais vous allez garage il est fait tout
seul mais je me porte à côté de moi ils
sont sûrs discorde ha ok ça va tout se
passe bien
un pote on m'avait demandé lui fait avec
dédicace à ce que je peux faire si je
trouve je t'écoute dédicace à s'assurer
au club en gros trop de charisme trop de
puissance en toi mec là ici je te laisse
vient bien dans leur plaît j'adore
attend est ce que c'est ok lequel le
quai les leviers de kanye west avait un
truc gentili a coupé le mage en deux
roues alors c'est quelqu'un qui souille
notre gueule parce qu'on dirait vraiment
c'est une capture d'écran mondiale g
capture d'écran mais non les gars je
suis là bas voilà vous avez mieux
expliquer le concept que moi du coup en
débris font ce que vous aviez sous les
yeux c'est incroyable ok je vous propose
maintenant de passer à l'avant dernière
celle dont je suis pas peu fier
[Musique]
non mais non mais c'est le jeu ben ouais
c'est le mec qui parodie c'est relou les
gars je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée
il ne voulait pas à percer mais regardez
cette énergie qu'il est juste que vous
avez tous des vacances elles vous ont
avec vous on fait tellement de bien oui
c'est très chiante pas là dans cette
position vous l'avez tous compris
yes yes
tu as repris exactement ce qu'il a fait
c'est simple tu as repris exactement ce
qu'il a fait c'est ce à quoi tu répètes
donc là tu répètes du jeu samedi là
monsieur au deuxième rang je vais vous
le verrez passer au tableau soubelet
ça tombe tout le temps sur moi
c'est relou sa cage à faire quoi fait un
x 2 plus 3 - 4 / la racine carrée de toi
bon bah j'ai complètement la chair oh
non j'ai entendu j'ai entendu ta soeur
derrière donc j'ai cru qu'ils allaient
faire ça
non c'est pas ma soeur c'est quoi ces
quotidiens maintenance et même des
photos de toi incrustant oui je me suis
impliqué c'est plus dur
[Musique]
thomas avec ton approche à l'état
incroyable mais cros et entraîne bégué
s'était pas quelqu'un quitte à les
imiter ou quoi ça donne des cours
celui-là il arrive c'est le prochain
il est pas mal hein je vais utiliser
cela je vais finir la vidéo avec sully à
bientôt mon pote car il tient mais voilà
les amis on est passé aux plus dures à
celui-là il est dur il faut être
vraiment bon de trouver et ce qui est
bien c'est que je peux parler et même si
j'arrive personnes pendant que je parle
pas garde mais ni entendu parler bâle
ville et je sais alors je me trouve pour
autant en mai s'explique échanger un pc
et j'en voyais un c'est quoi ton je vois
des deux pixelisé je vous laisse quand
même temps la regarde yanhai et moi
couleurs les couleurs éclatent à droite
c'est moi tu voyais bien joué
bien ouais c'est incroyable c'est
la première à trouver genre vraiment
aussi rapidement comme ça c'est
incroyable
merci la tension redescend la ya trop
d'ego attention là haut on va s'aimer
l'aristo mais où est-ce qu'ils aient
quoi je cherche depuis un mois une demi
heure je me suis fait la petite barre
bien coupé le petit dégradé tout ça pour
tomber sur un fake et ne pas le trouver
on dirait quand même beaucoup ce mois
peut-être bien ou bien c'est une bonne
imitation parce que ça ressemble à ça
avant mais passeront plus bien
ouej gauche essaie de provoquer les fans
de squeeze depuis ta la vraie joie sont
et ça marche pas en fait tantôt nation
ça va mais le timbre ses choix à prendre
en compte alors d'imitateur ok je peux
réessayer voisine alors est ce qu'il va
me trouver là c'était mieux là ouais ok
ok bon bah merci froid je te fais pas
perdre plus de temps bon courage pour
trouver squeeze merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis lequel tu viens du vers
l'ascenseur émotionnel mais c'est bien
moi où je vois rien eh ben il faut
ouvrir grand les yeux maintenant je suis
là regarde là bah oui je t'aide au nom
vous étiez 2 j'aurais pas dû céder à
deux vous auriez pu trouver bras les
filles passer une bonne soirée et puis
une bonne année et puis plein de bonnes
choses et au plaisir sur youtube merci
ça fait plaisir
ciao grand musée au sound system si vous
vous démerdez vous êtes grands super
laquelle je regarde je n'ai sachant qu à
pourquoi parce que vous êtes en vertical
non ils ont téléphoné à as tu vois là
quand je fais ça a donc tu m'as mi temps
il n'y a pas du tout la tête par dessus
tu vois que mon bras l'acquis vosges à
un verbe
bon ben c'est la fin bah ouais je suis
triste que sur la fin mais là il est à
l'époque je rentre mais franchement
c'est un marché de où tout le monde a
kiffé le concept de ya plein de moi il
faut trouver le vrai moi c'était assez
drôle et très mégalo extrêmement mégalo
j'espère que c'est cool à regarder je me
suis régalé à faire toutes les images
avec lorraine où on met plein mois on
s'attriste et c'est d'ailleurs senio qui
les as photoshopée gros bisogno merci
beaucoup parce que croyez moi incrusté
22 squeeze dans un d'amphithéâtre
c'est chiant aujourd'hui vous étiez
grave en forme c'est abusé quoi plus que
tout les faux je les fais avant je
trouve c'est étonnant parce qu'on est
peu de temps après la rentrée et où on
pourrait croire que des gens voient dans
un mauvais mood pas du tout vous étiez
tous le feu donc je veux plus jamais
entendre quelqu'un râler parce que c'est
la rentrée j'ai vu ce qu'il a fait sur
vous et vous péter le feu ok allez je
vous dis à bientôt je retourne en
vacances aller de son verre et voilà
c'est sympa au le petit nord inla on est
agréable non on dit l'agréable
j'ai trop parlé aujourd'hui c'est
charles
[Musique]